un état partial c'est ce que dénonce
aujourd'hui les indépendantistes de la
nouvelle calédonie en vue du référendum
prévu le 4 octobre prochain
en cause la publication d'un communiqué
sur les conséquences du oui ou du non à
l'indépendance ce document ne prendrait
pas en compte l les dernières
négociations notamment la période de
transition de trois ans réclamés par le
fln ks le parti indépendantiste à ses
membres des clubs temps au tour aux
mesures fixées en 2018
réponse du commissaire de la république
le texte je cite dit le droit de la
manière la plus neutre et la plus
impartiale possible à la toute puissante
administration de l'état n'a pas eu le
temps de travailler depuis le kobe 19 et
la nomination de jean castex l'état est
absent
nous aurions souhaité que l'état dise
concrètement en cas de oui comment il
entend mener cette transition mais la
vérité est qu à paris plus personne ne
connaît le dossier calédonien
l'état prend fait et cause pour le non
et on va écouter alban ben ça il est
anthropologue directeur d'études à
l'école à l'école des hautes études en
sciences sociales spécialiste de la
nouvelle calédonie si l'état français
laisse entendre qu'ils préfèrent que les
non-indépendantistes tous les ans qui
indépendantiste l'emportent
il est sûr que là il fait preuve de
partialité
si par contre il laisse le scrutin se
dérouler librement sans peser d'un côté
ou de l'autre
à ce moment là il est dans son rôle
d'ethan arbitre garant du processus
démocratique de décolonisation et c'est
tout ce qu'on lui demande
le référendum de du 4 octobre devrait
sinon confirmé en tous les cas les dents
même sens que celui de 2002 2018
il n'y aura pas de basculement
spectaculaire d
non-indépendantiste et les
indépendantistes en faveur des
indépendantistes